bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
assure public c'est l'un pour
l'ouverture de la session ordinaire du
parlement dans le cadre de leur semaine
de contrôle de l'action gouvernementale
et les sénateurs débattent cet
après-midi du financement de l'hôpital
début septembre un seul tour elle
ministre de la santé a lancé un nouveau
pacte de confiance pour l'hôpital elle
veut modifier le mode de financement de
l'hôpital tout en renonçant à une
convergence tarifaire public privé pour
la ministre l'hôpital ne doit pas être
seulement guidés par une logique
comptable même si elle n'entend pas
revenir sur la loi hpst hôpital patients
santé territoires votée sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy alors
qu'en pensent les sénateurs et bien tout
de suite direction l'hémicycle est bonne
après midi à tous madame mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues l'ordre du
jour appelle le débat sur le financement
de l'hôpital demande de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la ministre
vous voulez la parole je vous la donne
bien volontiers merci monsieur le
président simplement pour vous indiquer
évidemment d'abord le plaisir que j'ai à
être parmi vous pour ce débat qui était
un débat tout à fait majeure et je
remercie d'ailleurs les présidents
rapporteur de cette mission d'être venu
évoquer avec moi il y à cet après-midi
un séminaire gouvernemental organisé par
le premier ministre sur la réforme de
l'état
je devrais donc malheureusement vous
quitter vers 16h15 sans doute avant
d'avoir pu répondre aux interventions
des orateurs et donc je voulais m'en
excuser auprès de vous par avance vous
indiquez évidemment que je suis ces
débats de très près et le gouvernement
sera bien entendu présent par la
personne de madame dominique bertinotti
qui va suivre avec moi vos échanges et
vos interventions
merci madame la ministre souhaitait
prendre la parole tout de suite
si la commission est d'accord moi j'y
vois aucun inconvénient
non alors la parole et donc à monsieur
yves daudigny rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales
président de la mission d'évaluation et
de contrôle de la sécurité sociale
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
permettez moi en premier lieu de
remercier la conférence des présidents
et le gouvernement d'avoir inscrit ou
tout début de la nouvelle session
ordinaire ce débat si importants
relatifs au financement des
établissements de santé
la mission d'évaluation et de contrôle
de la sécurité sociale a travaillé sur
ce thème
six mois durant organisant 22 auditions
et tables rondes avec l'ensemble des
professionnels concernés se déplaçant à
lyon lille rennes laval avignon château
thierry et en seine saint denis
ce qui nous a permis de visiter des
établissements de santé dont les
conditions d'organisation et de
fonctionnement sont très diverses
présenté en juillet dernier notre
rapport a été adopté
je le souligne à l'unanimité par là
commission des affaires sociales madame
la ministre vous avez lancé plusieurs
chantiers d'envergure au sujet de
l'hôpital vous évoquerez sûrement tout à
l'heure le pacte de confiance que vous
avez initié et différentes autres
missions que vous avez également lancé
je me réjouis vivement que vous vous
soyez approprié ce sujet dès votre
domination car nous avons constaté lors
de nos auditions et sur le terrain les
attentes des personnels et des patients
qui ont été quelque peu déboussolés si
vous me permettez cette expression par
les réformes qui se sont succédé ces
dernières années à l'hôpital
d'ailleurs même si chacune chacun avait
naturellement son idée sur les réformes
passées et les améliorations à y
apporter
il nous a été souvent réclamé du temps
pour pouvoir les digérer et les mettre
en oeuvre sereinement
pour autant le champ d'étude de l'amex
se limiter ce qui était déjà ambitieux
au mode de financement des
établissements de santé et plus
précisément à la répartition des
ressources que l'assurance maladie leur
consacre je rappelle que ces dotations
s'élèvent à 75 milliards d'euros en 2012
dont 55 milliards pour les
établissements tarifs et à l'activité
c'est dire la place des hôpitaux dans
l'accès aux soins et dans l'
architecture de notre système de santé
la tarification à l'activité a été
introduite à partir de 2004 pour la
médecine la chirurgie et l'obstétrique
avec des mécanisme transitoire et des
coefficient géographique au recteur elle
consiste à fixer les tarifs
correspondant chacun à un paiement
forfaitaire par type de séjour un tel
système avec des modèles variable est
appliquée dans une grande majorité de
pays occidentaux
je limiterai mon intervention à quelques
remarques générales sur la situation
financière du secteur hospitalier
pour laisser du temps aux rapporteurs
pour laisser le temps aux rapporteurs de
présenter les conclusions de la mission
nous avons d'abord été surpris par la
faiblesse des indicateurs statistiques
et l'hétérogénéité des données publiées
or poser un diagnostic et envisager des
solutions suppose un constat partagé
l'autonomie des établissements ne
saurait justifier cette carence
car des statistiques bien plus fiables
existent pour les collectivités locales
dont la libre administration et reconnue
constitutionnellement
sous cette réserve on constate que le
déficit des établissements publics de
santé s'est établi à 488 millions
d'euros en 2010 ce déficit diminue
légèrement
et ils ne représentent globalement qu
une part faible des produits
d'exploitation 08
pour cent en 2010 de leur côté les
résultats du secteur privé commercial se
dégrade
pour autant ces résultats d'ensemble ne
doivent pas masquer d'importantes
disparités entre établissements ainsi
dans le secteur public
80 % du déficit reste concentré sur
moins de 50 hôpitaux pour l'essentiel
des chu dont plus de la moitié est dans
cette situation
le déficit de la seule ap hp s'est élevé
à 115 millions d'euros en 2010
deux éléments sont à prendre en compte
pour l'avenir
les dépenses d'investissement des
établissements publics ont doublé en dix
ans pour atteindre 6,4 milliards en 2010
leur dette a également doublé mais dans
les cinq dernières années seulement pour
s'élever à 24 milliards fin 2010 le plan
hôpital 2007 a de ce point de vue
enclencher une mécanique très critiqué à
juste titre par la cour des comptes
il en résulte un alourdissement durable
des charges d'amortissement et
d'intérêts d'emprunt qui pèse sur le
budget des établissements et rend
difficile pour certains d'entre eux le
retour à l'équilibré
la sensibilité des hôpitaux à
l'évolution des frais financiers est
devenu un élément à prendre en
considération pour l'avenir d'autant
plus que face à cette évolution
structurelle la crise financière rend
délicat de manière conjoncturelle
l'accès au crédit pour l'ensemble des
établissements
que ce soit en ligne de trésorerie de
court terme ou en emprunts de long terme
je précise madame la ministre que nous
aurons l'occasion d'évoquer différents
sujets ayant trait aux finances
hospitalière dans le prochain projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale notamment celui du tarif
journalier de prestations mais
pouvez-vous d'ores et déjà nous dire
quelles sont les mesures envisagées par
le gouvernement pour soutenir les
établissements
en ce qui concerne l'accès aux
crédit et les relations avec les banques
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à monsieur jacky le menn rapporteur
de la mission de d'évaluation et de
contrôle de la sécurité sociale vous
avez la parole monsieur le président
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues le rapport j'ai eu le plaisir
préparé dans le cadre de l'amex avec mon
collègue alain milon contient nombreux
éléments diagnostic de présentation mais
dans le temps qui nous est imparti je
vous propose plutôt de concentrer mon
propos sur nos conclusions et nos
propositions
comme l'indiquait l'instant notre
collègue yves daudigny président d'amex
la t2a la tarification à l'activité est
largement répandu dans les pays
occidentaux sous une forme ou une autre
et l'amex ne remet pas en cause le
principe d'une tarification à l'activité
est un point fort dont les atouts par
rapport au système antérieur du prix de
journée et de la dotation globale sont
indéniables nous en sommes convaincus le
financement des établissements doit
rester liés à leur activité pour
améliorer la transparence l'organisation
et les modalités de prise en charge la
tarification à l'activité la t2a a fait
l'objet de jugements très divers parfois
très tranchées très sévère car elle est
apparue comme un moyen de régulation
voire de contraintes
elle a indéniablement souffert d'une
extrême complexité d'une mise en oeuvre
technocratique insuffisamment
transparentes en outre ses modalités
on profite lui qu est d'une année sur
l'autre elle ne devait pourtant
constituer qu'un outil elle ne devrait
pourtant constituer qu'un outil de
répartition des ressources et une de nos
premières recommandations pourraient
être de ne pas tenter de faire jouer à
l'instrument plus qui n'est capable de
réaliser
on a parfois l'impression qu'à défaut de
pouvoir prendre des décisions en termes
de restructuration ou d'organisation on
a utilisé le levier la t2a celle ci est
a révélé des difficultés que l'on n'a
pas voulu
sucre était par ailleurs en outre son
application doit être plus prévisible
pour les établissements car on ne peut
mener à bien un projet si les tarifs
sont perpétuellement remis en cause sur
le fond maintenant nous avons constaté
que la t2a est peu adapté à certaines
activités médicales et à des territoires
isolés nous proposons d'une part de
travailler sur une nouvelle
classification commune des actes
médicaux la ccm et d'adopter une
classification cliniques permettant de
financer plus justement le temps médical
passer auprès des patients et d'autre
part de réunir des conférences de
consensus pluridisciplinaire pour
définir sur des critères médicaux des
activités pouvant relever d'un
financement au séjour
cette méthodologie partant du terrain et
concertée peut permettre de sortir de
certains affrontements stériles les
activités qui ne relève pas d'une telle
logique pourrait financer soit par un
système plus forfaitaire tout en gardant
un lien avec l'activité et j'insiste
soit par une dotation minimale de
fonctionnement constitutive d'une
fraction des coûts fixes dans le même
esprit des missions de service public
doivent être mieux couvertes et les
inégalités territoriales de santé mieux
prises en compte la présence
hospitalière dans une zone isolée ou peu
denses signifie des coûts fixes plus
élevés qu'ailleurs
alors que la logique de la t2a est celle
d'un calcul moyen national
je me permets à cet instant une
parenthèse notre mission n'a pas analysé
spécifiquement les difficultés
rencontrées par les outre-mer car la
commission des affaires sociales a
publié un an un rapport d'information
dédié aux questions de santé de logement
en martinique et en guyane
suite à une mission sur place conduite
par notre collègue madame muguette dini
alors président de la commission des
affaires sociales et un rapport a été
établi à la suite pour revenir à la t2a
nous avons pointé du doigt des
imperfections de la construction
tarifaire l'étude nationale des cours
repose sur un échantillon pro faible et
pas suffisamment représentatifs de la
diversité des établissements et des
retraitements statistiques permanent
nuisent à la lie
ibilité de l'ensemble au total le calcul
des coûts déjà un parfum est un fait
largement déconnectée de l'élaboration
de la grille tarifaire en outre à défaut
de la mise en place de réels outils pour
piloter l'activité
la france a choisi de facto une
régulation des dépenses par les tarifs
plutôt que par les volumes et ce à un
niveau macro économique sans prise en
compte de l'activité de chacun des
établissements
pris individuellement ceci explique que
les tarifs s'éloigne des coûts réels
constatés dans l'établissement ce qui
n'est pas satisfaisant pour les
gestionnaires et les équipes au
confluent des limites médical et
territoriale de la t2a se trouvent les
350 hôpitaux locaux ex hôpitaux ruraux
dont la loi prévoit qu'ils doivent
appliquer la tarification à l'activité
au 1er mars 2013
cette évolution nous semble inapproprié
car ces hôpitaux qui rendent un grand
service public de proximité seront
particulièrement frappés par deux
défauts actuels de la t2a il pratique
principalement la médecine gériatrique
avait peu d'actes techniques ils se
trouvent dans des zones isolées ou peu
denses en professionnels de santé sur ce
point madame la ministre
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement ce qui concerne le passage
à la t2a les hôpitaux locaux
plus globalement ne serait-il pas
opportun de commander une étude sur la
place de ces établissements qui
pourraient être utilement valoriser pour
répondre à certains défis actuels notre
système de santé
je voudrais évoquer maintenant un sujet
qui a été particulièrement décrié la
convergence la mise en place d'une
tarification liés à la thérapeutique
conduit presque instinctivement à l'idée
que le financement doit être égale quel
que soit le lieu
les modalités d'exercice où le patient
concerné or comme l'a montré la cour des
comptes le processus de convergence
intra sectorielle a déjà révélé les
limites de cette intuition ces limites
ne peuvent être que plus forte pour la
convergence intersectorielle entre les
grilles tarifaires le champ même des
tarifs est un différend entre les
secteurs privé et public
ce processus présente des biais
méthodologiques rédhibitoire que nous
avons signalé dans notre rapport alors
que des comparaisons ne pourrait
légitimement s'effectuer que toute chose
et
al par ailleurs des différences
fondamentales existe entre les
établissements santé en ce qui concerne
les modes de prise en charge les
contraintes d'organisation le coût des
personnels ou encore la capacité à
programmer son activité qui ne dépend
pas uniquement de la gestion
administrative pour médicale en outre
les tarifs repose aujourd'hui sur des
coûts moyens calculés à l'échelle
nationale dont la construction présente
se l'est dit certains défauts pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons notre rapport
qui je le rappelle a été adoptée à
l'unanimité de la commission des
affaires sociales comme le précisait le
président d'index demande la suspension
du processus de convergence tarifaire
pas dans les ministres vous avez annoncé
que vous proposerez cette mesure dans la
prochaine loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale je m'en félicite
un autre sujet a souvent été évoquée
durant nos auditions et des placements
l'investissement suite alliés
aujourd'hui il est presque exclusivement
financé par l'assurance maladie via le
fonds de modernisation des
établissements de santé et les tarifs
nous sommes interrogés
est ce légitime que le remboursement des
soins finances d'investissements
immobiliers ou les constructions
nouvelles d'établissements notamment
nous ne pensons pas dans le contexte
dégradée de nos finances publiques il
s'agit d'une réflexion bien sûr à moyen
terme mais nous sommes nécessaires d'une
part de remettre à plat les logiques de
financement et d'autre part de trouver
pour ce type de dépenses une meilleure
gouvernance afin d'optimiser les choix
des projets dans le champ des visas
c'est à dire la médecine chirurgie
obstétrique les tarifs représente 75 %
des financements ce qui est une part
certainement excessive comme nous
l'avons vu précédemment une part de 10%
obéit à des logiques diverses
principalement de paix le paiement
direct de certains médicaments onéreux
et de dispositifs médicaux ou des
forfaits pour des activités comme les
urgences les 15% restants font comme la
convergence l'objet de dissensions
constante entre les représentants des
hôpitaux et des cliniques
cet ensemble hétéroclite et nouveau
émouvant et regroupés dans la dotation
des missions d'intérêt général et d'aidé
à la contractualisation des migac man
army liste vous avez annoncé divers
groupes de travail
je crois qu'il serait utile de consacrer
1 à la remise à plat de ses migac qui
doivent être simplifiées et clarifier
pour conforter les missions de service
public de l'hôpital
par ailleurs nous nous sommes interrogés
sur la place des activités de recherche
et d'enseignement dans les mygales
cette dotation dit mary qui représente
quand même 2 7 milliards d'euros
représente environ le tiers des migac
alors que plusieurs de ces lignes relève
clairement de la responsabilité de
l'état
elle a beaucoup augmenté ces dernières
années a donc pesé sur l'ondam en tant
qu enveloppe fermée comme pour les
investissements immobiliers nous croyons
qu'il faut mener une réflexion sur la
répartition des responsabilités des
financières sur cette question des
mairies nous nous sommes également
intéressés aux modalités de régulation
macroéconomique des dépenses qui nous
semble comme à beaucoup d'autres acteurs
insatisfaisante
je le dis elle passe par l'ajustement à
la baisse des tarifs qui ont en pratique
baissé continûment ces dernières années
et par la mise en réserve annuel d'une
part des migac la construction et la
baisse des tarifs sont des symboles à
nos yeux des défauts de la mise en
oeuvre de la t2a en établissements dont
l'activité croît mais moins vite que la
prévision nationale voit ses recettes
baisser d'une année sur l'autre
c'est incompréhensible démotivant pour
les équipes médicales et soignantes
ainsi que pour les cadres de direction
des établissements
nous demandons en conséquence une
réforme globale de la régulation des
dépenses pour la rapprocher de
l'activité propre de chaque
établissement et éviter la mise en
réserve
infra annuel de crédits budgétaires un
autre élément est apparu durant nos
travaux
la t2a peuvent faire obstacle aux
coopérations suite à lierre car les
établissements nos intérêts ni à
partager nos activités ni même échangé
du temps médical
de ce fait la t2a peut se révéler
contraire un objectif politique pourtant
important nous pensons qu'il est
possible de donner aux agences
régionales de santé ars les moyens
d'attribuer de manière contractuelle des
financement temporaire
pour accompagner les coopérations
hospitalières à ce niveau je me permets
de vous poser une nouvelle question à la
ministre
comment entendez-vous conjuguer la
mécanique individualiste de la t2a avec
l'objectif de développement de la
coopération entre établissements
de manière générale nous estimons
nécessaire d'attribuer plus de marge de
manoeuvre à rs pour accompagner les
établissements dans leurs projets dans
un autre volet notre rapport souligne
que chacun nos déplacements a été
ponctuée par un sujet qui est
manifestement très mal vécu par la
communauté hospitalière
les contrôles de l'assurance maladie
réalisé sous l'égide de la rs leur
principe n'est aucunement remis en cause
ils sont essentiels dans un système de
tarification à l'activité
mais la pratique est là aussi
insatisfaisantes les personnels les
ressentent souvent comme effectués
systématiquement à charge et à la limite
de la remise en cause a posteriori bien
sûr de décisions thérapeutiques
restaurer la confiance et la sérénité
nécessaire ce qui passe par une
meilleure association des acteurs un
renforcement du pilotage national et
l'élargissement de la composition des
équipes de contrôle sur le terrain à des
praticiens vacataires exerçant en
établissement madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer qu'elles sont
aussi les intentions du gouvernement
sous cet angle je terminerai par un
point qui ne doit pas demeurer dans le
champ technique c'est le développement
et l'interconnexion des systèmes
d'information les capacités
technologiques existe dorénavant il
s'agit de les mettre en place de manière
coordonnée pour améliorer notre
organisation sanitaire
c'est une étape indispensable
développement concret de la notion de
parcours de santé
mais je laisse à ce sujet nous sommes
pas contre sens très bien évidemment la
parole à mon collègue à la mi longue
co-rapporteur est vice-présidente de
l'amex merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur alain milon
rapporteur de l'amex
bien monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues le jacky le menn a présenté
les principales propositions que nous
avons formulées pour revoir le périmètre
et fonctionnement d'un t2a je vais de
mon côté évoqué la question de la
qualité de la prise en charge des
patients
le premier aspect de la qualité des
soins c'est d'abord leur pertinence
il est certain que la mise en place des
t2 a entraîné un effet de rattrapage
dans le codage des actes puisque
l'amélioration de leur recensement a un
impact immédiat pour les ressources de
l'établissement ceci explique d'ailleurs
en partie la progression des espaces
dépenses hospitalières et cet effet
devrait s'estomper
il est extrêmement difficile d'isoler
les effets propres de la t2a dans la
mesure où elle interagit avec d'autres
facteurs mais une fraction significative
de l'augmentation de l'activité tient à
des facteurs indépendants de la
tarification les besoins de santé de la
population
le vieillissement de celle ci le
développement de maladies chroniques en
particulier d'autres phénomènes plus
critiquable contribue cependant au
développement de l'activité par exemple
madame le ministre le risque de
séquençage des séjours lorsqu'un patient
nécessite un nombre d'actes plus élevé
que celui sur lequel est fondée le coût
moyen son séjour et lorsqu il est
souhaitable de pratiquer un examen ou un
acte qui ne relèvent pas de sa
pathologie
si pâle et qui n'est donc pas intégrés
aux tarifs
l'établissement peut avoir intérêt à
laisser sortir le malade pour le faire
revenir quelques jours après par
ailleurs nous avons en particulier était
frappée durant l'entretien par
l'importance des actes pratiqués pour
des raisons de couverture médico-légal
du praticien au nom du principe de
précaution et dans la perspective
d'éventuelles contentieux il est
naturellement difficile d'avancer
qu'elle par des actes pratiqués ressort
de cette logique et plus gros mais
globalement quels sont ceux qui sont
inutiles ou superflus mettant la
fédération hospitalière de france que
plusieurs sociétés savantes ont montré
l'importance de ce type d'acte or s'ils
ont un coût pour la société il
n'améliore pas la qualité de la prise en
charge et peuvent le cas échéant avoir
un impact négatif sur le patient à cet
égard il est absolument nécessaire de
s'emparer de la question des
hospitalisations évitables des personnes
âgées qui sont catastrophiques pour leur
propre santé
plusieurs études l'ont démontré pour
cela mesdames les ministres il serait
intéressant de préconiser la création
d'un véritable service public de santé
qui constitue la pierre angulaire de la
stratégie de groupe du service public
hospitalier et médico social dans les
territoires de santé
cette politique que traduit non pas une
volonté d'aboutir à un système auto
centrée sur les hôpitaux publics mais au
contraire de servir de socle au service
des autres acteurs sur un territoire
donné
y compris en ce qui concerne d'ailleurs
le rôle du chu en matière d'enseignement
et de recherche
cela concerne aussi bien les acteurs de
soins libéraux que les maisons de santé
les services d'achat des ou de soins à
domicile que les acteurs médico-sociaux
art sociaux pour arriver à cet objectif
permettant à terme la création de
véritables filières de soins par type de
pathologie il est nécessaire de lever
certains obstacles ne permettant pas
d'aller dans ce sens la loi hpst avec
toutes ses qualités tous ses défauts à
proposer de nouveaux outils dans cet
esprit ainsi la cht a été l'un de ceux
là
il est nécessaire d'aller plus loin et
d'être plus volontariste en
réintroduisant la possibilité de créer
des cht intégré pour lutter contre ces
hospitalisations évitables nous
demandons à la haute autorité de santé
de mettre en place plus rapidement ces
référentiels et guide de bonnes
pratiques
en outre nous devons revoir la question
de la couverture assurancielle des
praticiens et des établissements afin
d'éviter la multiplication des actes
destinés à une couverture légale
l'amélioration des pratiques passera
nécessairement par une meilleure
formation à ces questions est essentiel
d'intégrer la dimension médico
économique et la pertinence des actes
dans l'ensemble des études de santé
initiale et continue madame le ministre
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement pour mieux évaluer pour
lutter contre ce phénomène préoccupant
d'actes inutiles ou superflus qui
concerne autant de médecine de ville que
l'hôpital avant d'en venir plus
directement à la question de la qualité
je souhaiterais dire quelques mots de la
télémédecine
la france reste clairement en retard
alors que ces nouvelles procédures sont
très prometteuses pour réduire à l'
isolement de certains patients et à
l'évolution de la démographie médicale
c'est pourquoi nous proposons que les
actes de télémédecine soit explicitement
inclus dans la grille tarifaire pour un
assurer la visibilité et la
après de longues discussions nous avons
estimé que la démarche de qualité qui
est indispensable apparaît modélisable
dans la système de financement sous la
forme de bonus
une telle action est nécessairement
protéiforme est complexe et il ne
faudrait pas à nouveau tenté de faire
jouer à la t2a à rolle dépassant
largement celui d'un outil de
répartition des ressources
pourtant on peut regretter que la france
soit plutôt timide sur ces questions les
indicateurs sont encore embryonnaires
est insuffisamment partagé alors même
que ce processus permettrait d'éviter
les palmarès qui fleurissent ici ou là
dans la presse et qui sont
malheureusement peu fondées
scientifiquement
nous proposons en conséquence le
déploiement d'une véritable stratégie de
qualité en confiant une responsabilité
explicite de supervision et de mise en
oeuvre à une institution indépendante
dotée pour cela de l'autorité suffisante
cette stratégie doit comme je voulais
d'y permettre de développer des
indicateurs de qualité et de sécurité
comprenant des sondages auprès des
patients et de leurs familles et des
personnels soignants
ces indicateurs doivent recevoir
également une large publicité
nous proposons tout de même d'envisager
une expérimentation qui consisterait
comme cela se pratique dans certains
pays à ne pas rembourser certains
séjours lorsque surviennent des
événements indésirables comme les
maladies nosocomiales
je souhaiterais enfin comme mia réalité
jacky le menn évoquer un sujet central
pour l'évolution structurelle de notre
système de santé
le parcours de santé évoquée depuis
quelques années dans de multiples
rapports cette notion doit maintenant
trouver une traduction concrète est
forte dans notre organisation
tout milite en ce sens le développement
des pathologies chroniques
le vieillissement de la population
l'évolution des demandes des patients et
de leurs familles
la transformation des conditions de
travail des professionnels de santé
qui plus est les techniques
informatiques autorisent aujourd'hui la
mise en oeuvre et zé le procédure
coordonnée entre l'ensemble des
professionnels
or la t2a peu surveillé par certains
aspects en contradiction avec la volonté
de développement du parcours de santé
en effet elle n'est pas organisée autour
du malade mais de sa maladie des
expériences étrangères existe et nous
devons avoir une approche pragmatique
voire expérimental pour identifier les
pathologies qui pourraient être
financées par une enveloppe globale
allant du diagnostic au traitement
curatif et aux soins postérieur nous
estimons d'ailleurs que la réforme à
venir du financement de soins des soins
de suite et de réadaptation doit être
pensé et conçu dans ce sens les
établissements nécessaire sincère par
nature dans une logique de parcours
puisqu'ils prennent en charge des
patients après leur hospitalisation dans
ce contexte mais dans la ministre
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement en ce qui concerne la
réforme du financement des activités de
soins de suite et de réadaptation qui
était initialement prévue pour 2013
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues le rapport
que nous avons
jacky le menn mois et ils d'audignies
brièvement présenté s'inscrit dans la
volonté d'améliorer les conditions de
prise en charge des patients dans le
cadre d'une enveloppe financière
contraintes absolument nécessaire pour
préserver
notre système de santé la t2a a beaucoup
apporté en termes de transparence et
d'organisation
mais elle reste un outil d'allocation de
ressources huit années après son entrée
en vigueur elle peut et doit être
améliorée à la fois pour prendre en
compte des activités ou des situations
qui se prête mal au financement par
tarifs et pour veiller à ce que la
pertinence et la qualité des prises en
charge reste en tout état de cause le
fondement du fonctionnement de nos
établissements jour merci merci monsieur
le rapporteur dans la suite du débat la
parole est à madame laurence cohen pour
le groupe crc
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues dire de
notre système de santé qu'il est
confronté aujourd'hui à des enjeux de
taille est un doux euphémisme
la crise financière économique et
sociale que notre pays traverse depuis
maintenant plusieurs années n'est pas
sans conséquences pour nos concitoyens
et les structures solidaires qui
participent à notre système sanitaire
d'un côté la dégradation massive de
l'emploi marqués par le dépassement
dramatique de 3 millions de chômeurs
affaiblit considérablement le
financement de notre protection sociale
et les déremboursements successifs les
franchises médicales
la hausse de la fiscalité sur les
mutuelles complémentaires ou les
sanctions financières en cas de non
respect du parcours de soins aggrave les
inégalités d'accès aux soins ainsi que
les renoncements pour motif économique
de l'autre les politiques qu'on t'a
d'austérité appliquées à l'hôpital
public sans discontinuer je pense
particulièrement à la tarification à
l'activité et à la convergence tarifaire
ont eu pour effet de fragiliser les
établissements publics de santé
à tel point que leur déficit constaté en
2010 est de 460 millions d'euros dont
334 millions pèsent sur 32 centres
hospitalo universitaires et je ne
mentionne pas ici l'obstination coupable
de certains à vouloir appliquer aux
hôpitaux les mêmes règles de
fonctionnement que les cliniques
commerciales qui se sont concrétisés par
la convergence tarifaire
puis la loi hpst transformant
progressivement les hôpitaux en deux
simples entreprise de soins
ce sont au final les deux volets
indispensables à la qualité des soins de
nos concitoyens qui sont remis en cause
les reculs en matière de soins
préventifs et de premier recours se
reportant naturellement sur les dépenses
hospitalières aggravant encore la
situation précaire des hôpitaux
c'est la raison pour laquelle au groupe
crc nous considérons qu'il est
impossible de revoir le financement de
l'hôpital sans mener de front une
politique plus globale intégrant par
exemple la lutte concrète contre les
déserts médicaux et les dépassements
d'honoraires
la lutte contre les entraves financière
aux soins de premier recours et
naturellement le financement durable et
solidaire de notre système de protection
sociale en même temps qu'il nous faut
donc ouvrir ces chantiers il nous faut
répondre aux besoins de financement de
l'hôpital public car il ya urgence
c'est notamment ce qu'a déclaré le
collectif notre santé en danger en
appelant la manifestation du 6 octobre
prochain lors de la conférence de presse
organisée jeudi dernier avec annie david
isabelle pasquet et moi même le sénat
contribuer à une recherche de nouveaux
financements et nous appuyons la
démarche qui est la sienne et qui est
défendu dans le rapport de l'amex
lorsqu'il préconise de mettre un terme à
la convergence tarifaire ce que vous
soutenez madame la ministre
or si le gel est nécessaire de nombreux
tarifs ont déjà été arrêtées sur la base
de ce processus d'assimilation du public
et du privé
aussi il nous faut tirer toutes les
conséquences de la proposition formulée
dans ce rapport et mettre fin à des
situations insoutenables pour les
établissements publics de santé
mais il faudrait également c'est en tout
cas notre conviction sortir de la
logique d'un financement prioritairement
assurés en fonction de l'activité
à défaut les fermetures massives de
service ou d'établissement de proximité
notamment les maternités et les centres
d'interruption de grossesse décidée par
les agences régionales de santé sans
concertation avec les populations
les personnels et les élus au seul motif
de leur non rentabilité se poursuivront
outre le caractère antidémocratique de
ces mesures nous ne pouvons accepter ces
fermetures
alors même que c'est précisément le mode
actuel de financement des hôpitaux qui
crée cette non rentabilité
le rapport de la mec sur le sujet est
clair lorsqu'il souligne que la t2a est
peu adapté à certaines activités
face à ce constat que nous partageons
nous considérons qu'une mesures
d'urgence s'imposent
l'instauration d'un moratoire sur la
fermeture de ces structures de santé en
même temps une grande concertation
réunissant 100 des acteurs de la santé
des économistes les partenaires sociaux
les élus doit s'ouvrir sur la création
d'un mode alternatif de financement sur
lequel l'activité serait certes prise en
compte mais où les missions sociales
ce public et les besoins des publics le
serait plus qu ils ne sont aujourd'hui
je suis naturellement conscientes que ce
mode de financement qui correspond au
plus près aux besoins des patients et
des établissements exige de renforcer la
part de financement dédié aux hôpitaux
et je dois dire au regard des éléments
déjà parues dans la presse faisant état
d'une évolution de l'ondam probablement
égal voire inférieure à celle de l'année
dernière que nous sommes inquiets une
telle évolution compte tenu du niveau
d'inflation prévisible conduire à
accroître lourdement la pression sur les
établissements de santé et
singulièrement les chu
or c'est un certain d'entre eux sont
dans des situations intenables et je
pense notamment à celui de caen vous le
savez
nombreux sont les établissements de
santé à équilibrer leurs comptes en
réduisant leurs principales dépenses
celles de personnel cela nuit à la
qualité d'accueil et de soins des
malades en même temps que cela dégrade
les conditions de travail des personnels
la fédération hospitalière de france
considère pour sa part que l'évolution
l'ondam devrait être d'au moins 3 5%
il semblerait que nous en sommes loin
dans ce contexte toutefois très tôt mis
en oeuvre pour desserrer l'étau
financier qui pèse sur les
établissements publics de santé
le poids des emprunts dont certains sont
toxiques n'est plus supportable et
privent bon nombre d'établissements des
ressources dont ils ont pourtant
cruellement besoin pour investir la
mecque ce fait la proposition que ces
financements ne repose plus sur les
tarifs et lui préfère par exemple un
financement par le biais du grand
emprunt pour le groupe crc il serait
utile pour les investissements relevant
de la dotation d'amortissement
équipements matériels lourds de revenir
à des emprunts à taux zéro auprès de la
caisse des dépôts et de consignation en
organisant la planification et la
transparence
avant de valider ses empreintes
préférentiels mais le recours à la
caisse des dépôts ne peut être qu'une
solution d'urgence et ne doit pas
redevenir le mode régulier de
financement des investissements
hospitaliers
à défaut on prendra le risque
d'accroître la facture que l'on constate
aujourd'hui où seuls les établissements
rentable pourrait supporter l'emprunt et
où les établissements les plus en
difficultés serait contraint à renoncer
aux investissements
on prendrait ainsi le risque de les
priver des capacités nécessaires
financière pour rendre possible
aux normes entraînant leur fermeture
pour motifs administratifs
il est donc impératif que les frais
d'investissement et de mise aux normes
dont on sait qu'ils sont grandissants
soit financée par l'état régler les
problèmes financiers de l'hôpital public
nécessite de faire preuve d'innovation
et d'audace
nous mettons ainsi en débat deux mesures
la suppression progressive de la taxe
sur les salaires qu'ils profondément
injuste et improductive la suppression
de la tva c'est à dire la possibilité de
récupérer la tva sur les investissements
comme pour les établissements et
cliniques privées nous sommes très
attentifs madame la ministre aux
annonces que vous avez faite concernant
notamment la révision la loi hpst et
comme le mouvement de défense de
l'hôpital public
je pense que cette révision suppose non
seulement une concertation comme vous
nous en avait fait pas avec les
professionnels et le représentant
l'institutionnel et syndicaux mais aussi
avec les associations de patients les
élus locaux et plus généralement la
population pour pouvoir déboucher sur
des états généraux à l'occasion de votre
présentation de 7,70 dernier de votre
pacte de confiance
vous avez dit madame la ministre avoir
une certitude celle que l'hôpital public
avait un avenir parce qu'il est le socle
de notre système de santé
vous avez parfaitement raison et ce
discours change de celui entendu par le
passé où l'hôpital n'était dépeint qu'en
termes négatifs est accusé de tous les
maux vous pouvez madame la ministre
monte sur la pleine mobilisation du
groupe cherchait à vos côtés dès lors
qu'il s'agira de permettre à l'hôpital
de jouer pleinement son rôle notamment
en réaffirmant la mission particulière
qui est la sienne au sein du service
public de santé qu'il est grand temps de
restaurer nos concitoyens ne sont pas
seulement attachés à leurs hôpitaux
ces derniers sont perçus pour ce qu'ils
sont des biens communs qu'il faut
pérenniser et développer pour l'avenir
et pour l'intérêt de toutes et tous
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
madame muguette dini pour le gru le
groupe uc r
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues en 2012
les dépenses de santé représentent 8% du
pib français et elle ne cesse de croître
côté recettes l'évolution est symétrique
et les assiettes s'érode associés à des
dégradation conjoncturelle
cette érosion produit des déficits
abyssaux de ces dernières années dans
ces conditions l'urgence d'une réflexion
sur le financement de la santé en
général et de l'hôpital en particulier
s'impose en effet le secteur hospitalier
participe avec le secteur ambulatoire
pour près de la moitié des dépenses de
santé soit 45% de l'ondam pour être plus
précis et 74 6 milliards d'euros ce qui
représente presque 4% du pib
si beaucoup reste à faire pour optimiser
le financement de l'hôpital
il faut reposer reconnaître cependant
que nous avons progressé en la matière
le financement par prix de journée en
vigueur jusqu'en 1984 pour les
établissements publics et privés à but
non lucratif et est inadaptée par
rapport à ce modèle inflationnistes et
ne correspondant à aucune pertinence
dans la prise en charge des patients la
dotation globale a constitué un progrès
la tarification à l'activité t2a a
représenté un nouveau pas en avant
la dotation globale avait un avantage de
taille
la maîtrise de la dépense mais
l'immobilisme et l'inadaptation des
activités hospitalières aux besoins
territoriaux de santé présenter des
inconvénients majeurs
c'est à ces inconvénients que devait
remédier la t2a huit ans après son
introduction
nous ne pouvons que souscrire au
remarquable bilan qu'en a fait la mecque
ce dans le rapport d'information de
jacky l'eau men et d'alain milon
du 26 juillet dernier et dont ils
viennent de nous parler avec beaucoup de
force
nous partageons le constat de ce bilan
oui la t2a a représenté un progrès ne
doit pas être remise en cause
mais non elle ne peut être l'alpha et
l'oméga du financement des
établissements
ce n'est pas une découverte depuis son
institution nous n'avons eu de cesse que
de stigmatiser certaines des limites les
plus flagrantes de la t2a laporte
derniers travaux de l'amex et de les
avoir listé systématiquement et de
proposer des solutions pour contrer
chacune d'entre elles nous enlèverons 3
pour nous les plus importantes
premièrement la t2a est davantage adapté
à la chirurgie et à l'obstétrique qu'à
la médecine deuxièmement la convergence
tarifaire nous a toujours semblé
utopique
compte tenu de la très grande diversité
des établissements de santé et des
difficultés inhérentes à certains
territoires
troisièmement l'enveloppent des missions
d'intérêt général et dead à la
contractualisation les migac qui devait
être levé verhaeghe la variable
d'ajustement entre secteur non lucratif
et cliniques et mal calibré ces trois
critiques vont loin parce que les
prendre en cause suppose de redessiner
le périmètre de la t2a nous devons aller
vers une nouvelle étape de livres lance
de l'évolution du financement de
l'hôpital vers un financement mixte 50%
de t2a et 50% d'un financement
comparable à ce qu'était la dotation
globale
en réalité ce financement mixte est déjà
en place puisque la t2a ne couvre
aujourd'hui que 75% de la dispense
hospitalière mais il ne pourra être qu
accentuer pour plus d'efficience et un
meilleur service rendu au patient la
critique de fond adressé à la t2a pour
notre collègue gérard roche lui-même
médecin
ces jeux site de trop prendre en compte
le volet technique de la santé au
détriment du volet humain remettre
l'humain au coeur du système de santé
suppose aujourd'hui
d'ajuster le système de la t2a mais il
est difficile de parler du financement
de l'hôpital sans dire un mot de ses
dépenses en septembre est sorti ouvrage
d professeur even et debré qui a fait
grand bruit
le guide des 4000 médicaments utiles
inutiles ou dangereux
la france consacre aujourd'hui par
habitant deux fois plus de dépenses de
médicaments que l'angleterre et un tiers
de plus que l'allemagne
et ce à performance de santé identique
une sur dépenses qui représentent 15
milliards d'euros 5 milliards de plus
que le déficit prévisionnel
en cause principalement la
surconsommation près de 30 % des
prescriptions hospitalières de
médicaments et des examens biologiques
et radiologiques
il serait injustifié ce constat est il
exagéré
pas tant que cela le sénat faisait déjà
un tel constat en juin 2006 dans son
rapport d'information médicaments
restaurer la confiance
constat réitéré avec force après l'
affaire du médiator par un nouveau
rapport de juin 2011 intitulé la réforme
du système du médicament enfin la cour
des comptes dégage également dans son
dernier rapport des marges importantes
d'économie hospitalière aujourd'hui le
groupe uc ifs et deux propositions
concrètes que l'igas et la cour des
comptes soient saisies conjointement
d'une mission sur le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital que notre haute assemblée
travail dès aujourd'hui à une nouvelle
propose une proposition de loi type loi
fauchon qui renforcerait la protection
des praticiens hospitaliers et libéraux
en matière d'engagement de leurs
responsabilités
aujourd'hui de telles dispositions
existent mais elles devraient être
renforcés étant donné que les praticiens
sur prescrivent pour se couvrir
en conclusion si le financement de
l'hôpital est une question clé
elle s'insère bien sûr dans le débat
plus large du financement de la
protection sociale que nous aurons bien
sûr à revoir
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame dini la parole est à
monsieur gilbert barbier pour le groupe
rdse
sur le président mesdames les ministres
mes chers collègues je voudrais tout
d'abord saluer le travail approfondi de
le collègue jacky le menn et alain milon
sur un sujet complexe
la t2a sujets souvent traités de façon
trop idéologique par ses partisans comme
par ses détracteurs
le rapport est avant tout pragmatique je
partage globalement leurs analyses sur
les a tous les défauts de la t2a
loin de remettre en cause son principe
des auteurs proposent des solutions pour
en améliorer la pratique beaucoup
d'entre elles me paraît souhaitable
financement activités d investissement
immobilier adoption d'une nouvelle
classification commune des actes
médicaux permettant de financer plus
justement le temps médical
j'ai d'ailleurs plaidé dans ce sens à
chaque paire fss stabilisation des
tarifs sur une base pluriannuelle pour
donner plus de visibilité aux
établissements en revanche je ne les
suis pas sur la proposition de suspendre
la convergence tarifaire
certes celle-ci ne serait être érigée en
dogme mais on ne peut ignorer le fait qu
une appendicite coûte jusqu'à quatre
fois plus cher dans un chu que dans une
clinique
la comparaison est certes complexe
puisque les jets à selle et j'ai un
assez sens clinique ne couvre pas les
honoraires j'admets qu'il y à des
variantes dans les modes de prise en
charge
aussi quel est le contenu qui peut être
donné au mot suspension s'agit-il
d'abandonner tout simplement le principe
de la convergence tarifaire est alors
que souhaitons faire quoi qu'il en soit
cela me paraît un renoncement
essentiellement politique
je m'interroge également sur
l'opportunité de suspendre le passage à
la t2a pour les hôpitaux locaux est
nécessaire aujourd'hui très coûteux dans
le cadre d'un ondam fermé
les auteurs aussi mener une réflexion
très intéressante sur la qualité la
pertinence des actes de ces jours de
fête
on constate de surprenantes variations
régionales sur des interventions
courantes comme les césariennes napanee
secte ami les angioplasties ou encore la
libération du canal carpien alain milon
a évoqué également 28% des actes qui ne
sont pas pleinement justifié qu'il soit
dû au caractère inflationniste de la t2a
ou à la volonté des médecins se prémunir
d'éventuels contentieux
il y as probablement là madame le
ministre d et communiquent autant ciel
qui mérite d'être explorée
car soyons lucides la t2a est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt on ne peut tout
demander un système de financement c'est
de l'art fondation de l'hôpital dont il
faut parler il y à des établissements en
grande difficulté qui vivent
d'expédients d'être ponctuel du
ministère de ligne de trésorerie de plus
en plus difficiles à renouveler
c'est le cas de plusieurs chu sê été
soulignée projets qu'il mène le sujet
préoccupant le poids de l'histoire des
investissements mal calibré un recours
massif à l'endettement ou déséquilibrer
la situation financière des îles et en
même temps de très bons résultats les
déficits ne sont pas inéluctables
certains établissements sont à l'
équilibre avec les mêmes tarifs que les
autres
d'autres y sont revenus en se
réorganisant de fond en comble afin d' à
lui est alloué au mieux la ressource
sans perdre en qualité de prestation
aujourd'hui comme ça a été dit qu'après
la portion du déficit sont concentrées
sur moins de 50 établissements pour
l'essentiel des sièges sur ces derniers
ont eu tendance à négocier des moyens
supplémentaires
plutôt que de rechercher de meilleure
efficience par des réformes
structurelles
la cour des comptes soulignait
d'ailleurs que c'est ch y bénéficier de
modalités de financement plus favorables
que les autres hôpitaux publics alors
que leurs spécificités et finalement
toute relative
l'activité spécifique du chu
représenterait selon l'ate y devient 14%
de l'activité le reste relevant du
commun par ailleurs certains ne font que
peu ou pas de recherche et perçoivent
pourtant la dotation correspondante le
déficit hospitalier de nous interroger
sur le nombre des établissements de
santé
le rapport de nos collègues mérite bien
des jeux des loges mais il évite ce
sujet qui fâche
n'y at il pas trop d'hôpitaux faut-il
enfermés ou à arrêter certaines
activités dans certains pour moi la
réponse est clairement oui
même si elle n'est pas politiquement
correct
cette position d'ailleurs n'a rien de
comptable elle repose sur une exigence
légitime la sécurité la qualité des
soins
qui d'entre nous préfèrent gré un
chirurgien qui pratique un type
d'intervention trois fois par an à celui
qui la pratique trois fois par jour
d'ailleurs les patients ne s'y trompe
pas en dépit de ce que ça peut leur
coûter 80 % des actes de programmer sont
effectuées dans des cliniques privées
dans la marne département très
intéressant puisqu'il ya très peu
d'offres à tarifs opposables 40 % de la
clientèle vient des départements voisins
ou bien chercher des soins dans le
département de la marne alors qu'on
n'est pas forcément bien en bourse et la
loi hpst avait des défauts certes l
encourager à leur restructuration des
hôpitaux avec notamment les coopérations
cela permet une meilleure spécialisation
gaz une sécurité accrue de juin ou en
étant la t2a peut être un obstacle bien
sûr mais les élus locaux aussi alors que
de nombreuses cliniques ont fermé dans
l'indifférence totale
dès qu'on touche à l'hôpital tout est
bloqué j'ai fait partie d'une commission
chargée par madame bachelot narquin de
donner un avis sur la fermeture de 127
plateaux de chirurgie considéré comme
insuffisant
ce programme a été enterré par xavier
bertrand mais certains de ces plateaux
sont toujours peu fiables en termes de
sécurité des fermes et permettrait
peut-être de réallouer des financements
au plateau qui fonctionne correctement
la mission de l'hôpital et de soigner et
non de maintenir des emplois
et j'ajouterais qu'il n'a pas vocation à
être un lieu où convergeraient par des
fautes ce qui ne peut pas trouver
solution ou réponse organisée
l'hôpital est là pour fournir au bon
moment un apport puissant de compétences
cliniques et techniques
la tarification parcours que proposent
nos colonnes le nail millions par le
rapport est une notion très intéressante
avec le développement des pathologies
chroniques qui représentent plus de 60%
des dépenses de santé
il y assure mme en intérêt à trouver un
mode de tarification incitant un travail
soigné en plus transversal entre
l'hôpital des soins de ville elles
médico social appuyé sur des formes
d'exercice pluri appartenant t pluri
professionnelle
pour conclure il convient d'anticiper
les mutations de l'hôpital ce qui ne
passera pas nécessairement par la t2a
aujourd'hui les questions essentielles
sur la gestion des maladies chroniques
de l'organisation des soins en amont et
en aval de l'hôpital nous
l'hospitalisation en ambulatoire et de
la concentration des plateaux techniques
de qualité
il est surtout urgent d'effectuer des
travaux sur la pertinence des soins et
sur les actes inutiles
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
la parole emad a atteint madame aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologie
bien monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres
mais ce les rapporteurs chers collègues
spontanément les écologistes sont
associés et on peut le comprendre à la
défense de la nature
ce n'est toutefois pas la nature en tant
que tel qui nous importe si nous sommes
si nous sommes si attachés à la protéger
c'est parce qu'elle constitue notre
environnement notre milieu et que de sa
qualité dépend celle de notre vie si on
peut comprendre que dans la situation
actuelle le président de la république
est consacrée comme prioritaires
l'éducation la justice et la sécurité
il ne nous semble par ailleurs pas
inutile de réaffirmer ici que préserver
la santé nos concitoyens
reste bien sûr une des missions les plus
fondamentales qui incombe aux pouvoirs
publics pour pouvoir être mené à bien
notre politique de santé publique
doivent évidemment s'appuyer sur un
système de financement solide pour
autant il convient aussi de s'interroger
sur la pertinence de la notion de
rentabilité toujours sous-jacente à ce
débat l'objectif que nous devons
assigner un autre système hospitalier et
de nature sanitaire pas financière a
trop parlé de rentabilité de l'hôpital
on arrive vite à parler de rentabilité
du patient et à considérer les décisions
médicales au travers du seul prisme
économique
c'est ainsi que l'on se retrouve engagé
des soins pas forcément indispensable
parce qu'ils rapportent plus qu'ils ne
coûtent à la structure hospitalière ou
au contraire à en négliger d'autres par
crainte d'une grève davantage le déficit
s'est également de cette manière que
l'hôpital est amené à se rapprocher du
fonctionnement de l'entreprise avec des
prestations qui commence à revêtir à
gracc terre commercial
les niveaux de confort différents
appelle d'ores et déjà des tarifs
différents pour décider d'attribuer une
chambre individuelle à un patient plutôt
qu'à un autre
il existe pourtant de nombreux critères
possibles par exemple médico sociaux ou
psychologiques plus pertinent que leur
pouvoir d'achat respectifs à trop se
déporter vers des indicateurs
économiques sophistiqués on a parfois
tendance à perdre de vue l'objectif
auquel concours les dépenses que l'on
engage cette approche fondée sur la
rentabilité n'est pas compatible avec un
service public aussi essentiel que celui
de la santé d'ailleurs personne ne
s'interroge
du moins pas encore sur la rentabilité
de l'armée de l'éducation nationale ou
de la police pourtant elle aussi
contraintes intérieures de budgets
serrés
toutefois bannir la notion de
rentabilité ne signifie pas pour autant
dépenser aveuglément
bien au contraire il convient d'évaluer
les besoins sanitaires des territoires
avec leurs spécificités locales puis
l'efficacité regarde ses besoins des
moyens mis en oeuvre le rapport de la
mission propose à cet égard
d'intéressantes évolution premièrement
il y ait suggéré un rôle accru des ars
agences régionales de santé
une meilleure prise en compte des
spécificités des hôpitaux locaux et des
inégalités territoriales
deuxièmement en ce qui concerne la
tarification à l'acte instrument central
du système actuel de financement
la mission a mené un travail d' analyses
poussées mettant en évidence les limites
du dispositif
il est ainsi proposé de mieux prendre en
compte les coûts fixes des hôpitaux
publics liés à leur mission d'intérêt
général de circonscrire lusage la
tarification à l'acte au seul secteur
d'activité qui s'y prêtent et ainsi
ainsi que de trouver des marges de
financement pour l'innovation et
l'investissement
ces propositions vont dans le bon sens
et il appartiendra à la mission d'en
évaluer l'impact
le rapport fait également
une autre proposition forte la
suppression de la convergence entre le
public et le privé
plusieurs collègues à vos avant moi ont
abordé cette question reconnaissant que
les grilles tarifaires des secteurs
public et privé ne recouvre pas les
mêmes charges
les écologistes souscrivent pleinement à
cette proposition
si importante pour la sauvegarde de
l'hôpital public
toutefois la question de la convergence
n'est pas le seul problème lié à
l'immixtion du secteur privé au sein
même de l'hôpital public
par exemple aujourd'hui un nombre
croissant de patients se trouvent piégés
par les dépassements d'honoraires
lorsqu'ils tentent de prendre rendez
vous pour une consultation avec un
praticien hospitalier le choix devant
lequel il se retrouve placé consiste en
un mélange de fête de vente forcée et de
refus de soins
souvent on leur propose d'opter soit
pour rendez-vous en libéral dans des
délais très courts soit pour une
consultation dans le public avec le même
praticien qui serait moineau moins
onéreuses ne pourrait avoir lieu que
dans des délais très longs
cela est il normal nous ne pensons pas
d'autant plus qu'en général la
réputation qui permet à ces praticiens
d'exercer ces consultations privet ya
essentiellement au prestige qu'ils
tirent de leurs titres et de leur
fonction publique
mesdames les ministres nous comptons sur
votre diligence pour que cette situation
soit analysée et prise en compte au plus
vite qu'il y va de l'égalité en matière
d'accès aux soins qui ne doit pas être
que territoriales mais également
sociales enfin nous nous félicitons que
la qualité des soins pour les patients
question centrale
s'il en est est constitué une réelle
préoccupation de la mission là encore
ces préconisations visant à développer
une véritable démarche de la qualité au
niveau tant national que régional
préfigure une stratégie que nous
soutenons fortement et dont il
conviendra d'assurer un suivi dans la
durée
pour conclure je voudrais rappeler ici
que la meilleure politique de santé
reste pour nous celle de la prévention
non seulement elle garantit meilleure
qualité de vie évidemment aux individus
dont elle permet d'éviter les infections
mais même d'un strict point de vue
financier
d'un strict point de vue financier elle
permet de générer de substantielles
économies
cela sort toutefois un peu du cadre de
ce débat et de tout cela nous
reparlerons lors des discussions
imminente sur le plfss
je vous remercie merci ma chère collègue
la parole est au président gérard
larcher pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
président de l'amex messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues je
voudrais cadres et mon intervention de
cet après midi sur l'investissement tout
d'abord un constat les investissements
hospitaliers son créateur de richesses
et source d'amélioration de la qualité
des prises en charge
il doit donc être soutenus sous l'effet
des plans hôpital 2007 et 2012
les investissements hospitaliers ont été
fortement soutenue je le rappelle 6
milliards 4 en 2010 6 milliards 4 en
au total de 2002 à 2010 un doublement
des dépenses d'investissement et une
stimulation qui a permis d'engager une
forte modernisation des équipements
hospitaliers répandant d'ailleurs aux
attentes de la communauté hospitalière
c'est d'efforts a été réalisé en grande
partie par une politique nationale de
soutien à l'endettement des
établissements qui a eu pour conséquence
naturelle la croissance de la dette des
hôpitaux de 18 milliards d'euros à 30
milliards d'euros
conséquence normale c'est d'ailleurs
l'observation de la cour des comptes en
juillet dernier n'y a que
l'accroissement des dettes des hôpitaux
ne soit pas un signe de mauvaise gestion
elle peut être prêt que préoccupante
pour certains établissements et leur
indépendance financière et ceux
actuellement plus encore dans un
contexte de raréfaction du crédit et
d'augmentation des marges bancaires
la modernisation du parc hospitalier me
paraît devoir être poursuivie et le
maintien à niveau des équipements
hospitaliers rend indispensable il la
poursuite d'une politique dynamique
d'investissement comme priorités
stratégiques
ainsi malgré le contexte par
culièrement contre un pour les finances
de notre pays n'apparaît que les
pouvoirs publics doit pas céder à la
tentation de réduire programmatiquement
les investissements hospitaliers
ceux ci doivent être soutenus en raison
du potentiel de modernisation de
croissance de réponse aux besoins de
santé mais aussi parce qu'ils conduisent
à la maîtrise des dépenses
l'évolution du paysage sanitaire en
particulier les nouvelles modalités de
prise en charge ambulatoire le poids des
maladies chroniques le vieillissement de
la population
tout cela va inévitablement entraîner
une modification profonde du rôle et de
la place des établissements de santé et
parcours de soins sur le rapporteur des
filières l'essor de la télémédecine le
poids des contraintes énergétiques qu'on
en parle très peu mais c'est quelque
chose d'important
le décloisonnement sont autant de
réalités qui vont s'imposer et qui vont
transformer le positionnement la
physionomie et la nature d'activité d'un
certain nombre d'établissements et la
concentration relative des plateaux
techniques est d'ailleurs en cours
je pense que les ailiers y compris à la
démographie des compétences et au choix
d'implantation territoriale qui est
souvent motivé
d'un côté par helios et j'allais dire
comme le séisme autour du chu
plus on s'éloigne du chu et plus la
démographie médicale et celle des
compétences est difficile à résoudre et
l'égalité territoriale
c'est aussi cela et cela d'abord selon
les évaluations conduites et je pense
celle conduite par la fédération
hospitalière de france
les besoins courants en investissements
devraient s'élever à 4 milliards et demi
d'euros chaque année
je pense que ce seront des
investissements assez différents de ceux
qui ont été réalisés ces dernières
années dans le cadre des plans notamment
pital 2007 et hôpital 2012 aux
constructions massives succéderont des
opérations de densification du
patrimoine hospitalier existants
les investissements destinés à
accompagner la stratégie de groupe
public mais également des programmes de
renouvellement des équipements
biomédicaux et de développement des
systèmes d'information car l'homme les
ministres nous avons un retard
considérable que dans un certain rapport
en 2007 nous avions souligné et qui
malheureusement n'a que peu progressé
la faiblesse l'absence parfois fiabilité
nos systèmes d'information j'allais dire
sont que la performance n'est parfois
pas au rendez vous simplement parce que
nous n'avons pas suffisamment investi
pas simplement en moyens matériels mais
en moyens humains sur les systèmes
d'information
longtemps au système actuel de
financement des investissements il me
paraît qu'il a montré ses limites il
importe aujourd'hui de poser les bases
d'une nouvelle stratégie de financement
c'est peut être l'objet du débat que
nous pouvons aussi avoir pour les temps
qui viennent
le modèle de tarification à l'activité
est censé permettre le financement des
investissements sur le cycle courant de
l'exploitation
or le mécanisme même de construction
tarifaire a depuis son origine
entretenir un flou quant à la part
destinée dans les tarifs au financement
des investissements et on le voit bien
d'ailleurs dans les rapports annuels qui
sont renvoyés devant lé conseil de
surveillance quant aux agences
régionales de santé font des
observations nous voyons bien que nous
allons toujours en fonctionnement et
rarement à l'investissement dans
l'urgence annuel d'un ne perdait que
nous recevons en général définitivement
arrêtée en juillet alors que je le sais
l'année continue a commencé le 1er
janvier ce qui nous met parfois dans une
situation singulière mais surtout le
caractère forfaitaire et égalitaire
détail sort c'était égalitaire place en
réalité les établissements dans les
situations disparates
parce que les établissements sont aussi
disparates par rapport à
l'investissement qui doivent consentir
c'est précisément en raison de cette
limite que les pouvoirs publics avaient
mis en place des systèmes
d'accompagnement financier contractuels
les crédits dead à la contractualisation
connaissent bien ou deux rapporteurs or
ceux ci sont non seulement
j'allais dire est suffisant mais aussi
de plus les établissements à s'endetter
une stimulation à un moment
difficilement tenable notamment sur une
longue période
alors dans votre rapport de la mec sans
juillet dernier consacré notamment la
tarification à l'activité me semble que
vous avez clairement mis en évidence les
limites du système tarifaire actuelle
pour financer les investissements
notamment et je partage nombre de points
qui ont été soulignées dans le rapport
trois priorités selon vous était à
l'ordre du jour clarifier les règles de
financement des investissements revoir
la procédure de choix des projets et
ensuite mettre en accord le choix du
financement avec la nature de
l'investissement c'est me semble-t-il un
point extrêmement important à court
terme
il faut donc construire un mode de
financement d investissement pérenne qui
préserve l'autonomie des établissements
de santé et renforce les tissus ans des
projets conduits la définition d'un
nouveau mode de financement des
investissements hospitaliers doit
s'inscrire dans la réflexion plus
globale sur l'évolution du modèle
tarifaire plusieurs propositions tendant
à dessiner ce nouveau mode de
financement des investissements
tout d'abord en premier lieu il me
semble que l'ensemble des acteurs
aujourd'hui me paraît s'accorder sur la
nécessité pour que ce nouvel nouveau
modèle ne soit plus uniquement liée à
l'activité des établissements
en effet nos hôpitaux sont hétérogènes
dans leurs activités dans la population
accueillie et il ne doit pas se traduire
cette elle ne doit pas se traduire cette
hétérogénéité par une impossibilité de
conduire des investissements dans un
certain nombre de cas ensuite le nouveau
modèle de financement des
investissements me semble-t-il devra
privilégier des dotations ou subventions
capital plutôt que l'endettement
l'endettement ne doit plus être le
résultat de stimulation de court terme
des pouvoirs publics mais redevenir une
décision autonome des intérêts des
établissements prise en responsabilité
en conscience enfin il faut rechercher
la diversification des sources de
financement tant par les fonds propres
que dix empreintes mais une autre piste
doit être privilégiée l'appelle plus
large des fonds régionalisés je pense au
cder et l'ademe devra être envisagée de
même pourquoi pas la possibilité au
travers des fondations de faire appel à
des dons tout ceci est encore balbutiant
dans notre pays pour ce qui concerne les
emprunts la crise des liquidités
bancaires rend incontournable une
évolution du modèle actuel le futur
ensemble banque postale caisse des
dépôts devra jouer un rôle majeur dans
la politique de prêt hospitalier mais
pour cela il est souhaitable que les
hospitaliers soient associés à la
gouvernance du groupe bancaire public
parce que avant qu'il n'ait compris la
réalité d'un hôpital
je peux vous garantir que nous aurons
plusieurs années ils ont déjà du mal
avec les collectivités territoriales
qu'en sera-t-il avec l'hôpital
nous devons trouver des réponses rapides
notamment pour l'hôpital public
nos renforcements l'évaluation de la
performance enfin des investissements me
paraît une dimension incontournable pour
accompagner l'évolution du modèle de
leur financement
l'élévation de l'efficience la
surveillance plus étroite des résultats
obtenus la responsabilisation des
décideurs hospitaliers me semble des
priorités à concrétiser voilà pourquoi l
agence nationale d'appui à la
performance peut utilement ou lavier
proposait mettre à profit son savoir
faire pour aider les hospitaliers dans
cette voie pour autant que cette aide ne
soit pas conçu comme une tutelle
supplémentaire exercée au nom des
pouvoirs publics puis long terme la
problématique du financement des
investissements renvoie au modèle même
d'organisation hospitalière
il appartient aux hospitaliers d'être à
la hauteur de leurs responsabilités de
dessiner les contours d'une organisation
hospitalière renouveler reposant sur la
stratégie groupe public avec pour
principe cardinal la mutualiser
sur la complémentarité comme un ami dont
je crois qu'il faudra aller plus loin
pour conclure madame la ministre et je
sais que les contraintes
gouvernementales vous empêcheront porter
la réponse néanmoins quatre questions et
puis vous me répondrez peut-être plus
tard les trésoreries de nombreux
établissements sont tendus et nécessite
une intervention rapide des pouvoirs
publics
quelle réponse fait le gouvernement aux
propositions qui ont été faites par la
fédération qui représente les hôpitaux
publics
c'est une première question le plan
hôpital 2012 deuxième question a été
gelée de l'envoi aux établissements de
santé ont engagé des chantiers
ils sont dans l'attenté du déblocage
produit d'une deuxième tranche
qu'en est il du déblocage du plan pour
éviter les arrêts de chantier toujours
coûteux toujours complexe si je peux me
permettre je le souvenir du plan de
leurs deux qui avaient bloqué un
établissement que je connais bien et qui
nous avait mis en grande difficulté
donc je crois qu'il faut des réponses
claires pour les établissements enfin
les pouvoirs publics ont toujours
affirmé la nécessité de développer j'y
reviens les systèmes d'information santé
considérés par beaucoup dont moi même
comme une priorité nationale
que compte faire le gouvernement pour
relancer ses investissements
prioritaires et je dois dire que je n'ai
pas toujours été très amènes avec le
précédent gouvernement sur ce sujet
parce que il me sens que ce sujet est
primordial enfin l'inquiétude des
hospitaliers sur l'accès à l'emprunt
je les ai évoqué lui un instant ceci me
paraît tout à fait important
l'investissement c'est l'avenir et
l'investissement doit se faire dans une
conception nouvelle sans doute de
l'hôpital je suis bien que gilbert
barbier abordés d'une manière très
directe certain nombre de sujets qui
fâchent mais au fond la question c'est
pas de savoir le nombre d'établissements
qu'on aurait affirmé je pense qu'ils ont
tous une utilité mais ils doivent avoir
une utilité complémentaires différentes
pour que la réponse en terme de qualité
de soins soit identique sur tout le
territoire
or ça n'est pas vrai qu'il y a une
réponse en qualité qui est soit égal ce
n'est pas le
nombre les établissements c'est les
compétences sur le territoire c'est des
réponses techniques et cette réalité là
nous avons le devoir au delà des
sensibilités que nous avons les uns les
autres d'y apporter une réponse parce
que la spécificité de l'hôpital public
est une spécificité française
elle doit se faire me semble-t-il dans
la qualité et dans la dignité de ceux
qui sont accueillis je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur serge larcher
pour le groupe socialiste monsieur le
président madame la prise de la
commission sociale
mesdames les be nice messieurs les
reporters mais j'ai roulé dans le débat
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui sous l'eau
pitt le financement de métal public il
me revient qualité de président la
délégation sénatoriale à l'outre-mer de
traiter de la question particulièrement
délicate des hôpitaux sur ces
territoires
comme dans bien des matières là où la
situation est grave en france
pique hexagonal et les gras matic dans
nos régions éloignées
je vais voici passé principalement
illustrer mon propos par l'exemple des
hôpitaux martinez mais ce que je vais
évoquer pour le chu de fort de france
est largement transposable à celui de
pau tape it et à la magie de la majeure
partie des hôpitaux outre-mer dossiers
de ces hôpitaux n 12 est un dossier
compliqué voire effrayant par l'ampleur
des chantiers ainsi fin 2011 des trois
principaux hôpitaux de la martinique
accuse déficit cumulé de 147 millions
d'euros
les causes d'une telle situation sont
multiples certaines relèvent de
problèmes d'orientation et de gestion
qu'il convient de traiter
il s'agit en particulier des doublons
d'activités des problèmes de
sureffectifs pas tant dans les soins que
dorée secteur administratif et technique
des incertitudes quant à la qualité de
gestion s'agissant notamment du circuit
de facturation et de la multiplication
des crises découvrable
cependant il serait trop facile de se
contenter cette part de l'explication
il convient également d'examiner les
causes structurelles des grandes
difficultés que rencontrent les hôpitaux
outre mer est une fois de plus on ne
revient nécessairement à la question de
l'éloignement d'un dollar us nationalité
et de la faible taille des populations
de chaque territoire concerné en effet
certains activités une âme ou parfois
même était régionale génère presque
nécessairement un surcoût on peut
prendre l'exemple des grands brûlés de
l'année où surgit ou encore la chirurgie
cardiaque
ces activités ne peut pas être rentable
aux gars du bassin de bassin de
population dont la dimension est trop
faible pour autant doit-on renoncer à la
à prodiguer ses soins à nos populations
autre exemple le supportant une
majoration anormale du tarif des
produits sanguins labiles ceci au tarif
qu'on présente un coût de plusieurs
millions d'euros chaque année pour nos
hôpitaux
par ailleurs même entre les outre-mer
pour constate sur ce point d écart
inexplicable de territoire à goutte
c'est alors se pose la question la
solidarité nationale de toute évidence
en l'état des choses
certains coûts ne sont pas assez
compensé par l'état au titre des crédits
assurances maladie ainsi le coach tient
le coefficient géographique qui nous
accueille est appliquée de 26% alors
même que l'état c'est pour avoir les
avoir pas fait oublier que c'est sur
coup son nom et du petit bhl et son
supérieur à 13%
mesdames les ministres chers collègues
il ne s'agit pas pour moi de près de
prétendre que l'organisation est
parfaite et que tout n'est que faute de
moyens financiers
il s'agit cependant d'attirer votre
attention sur le fait que la rénovation
puis la réorganisation hospitalière et
plus largement celle de location est
vouée à l'échec si on ne traite pas le
problème de fond et sur coup il faut
donc un engagement fort de l'état pour
accompagner
les hôpitaux où le pro maire en
conclusion je constate donc la nécessité
de réorganisation de l'hôpital public
afin qu'il soit plus performant mais la
notion de performance ne possède pas
exclusivement une logique économique
la performance est celle d'un système de
soin à la fois capable à la fois de
traiter de bien traiter tous les
patients où qu'ils se trouvent de mieux
prendre en charge les plus vulnérables
et enfin de faire progresser la
recherche
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à monsieur rené paul
savary pour le groupe ump tient bien
mais monsieur le président madame le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission monsieur le président de la
mecque ce monsieur le rapporteur la t2a
est une tarification largement
appliquées en europe
en france nous avons été plus loin que
d'autres pays sur le champ concerné par
cette tarification à l'activité est
aujourd'hui l'obstacle fonctionne pour
une part très importante de ses recettes
de taiseuse a en somme pour une
appendicectomie
quel que soit l'établissement la
sécurité sociale verse un certain
montant à l'hôpital et pour affiner tout
cela un grand nombre de critères sont
pris en compte et la façon dont le
séjour se passe à l'hôpital est aussi
analyser en bref c'est un énorme
algorithme qui permet de déterminer quel
tarif sera perçue par l'hôpital et ce
n'est pas forcément la réalité
économique autant le dispositif
précédent et cela a déjà été souligné
le forfait global gommer les différences
liées aux activités ce qui était source
d'immobilisme autant la t2a peut être
une course à l'activité et son
application depuis quelques années
mérite est véritablement un examen
approfondi ce qui a été fait à travers
de ce rapport de façon très perspicace
que les auteurs ou soit largement
remercié
je voudrais simplement à travers mon
propos souligné quelques imperfections
dont il faudra peut-être envisager la la
correction à la ministre dans une
première partie je vous fait part de
quelques réflexions en deuxième partie
je commenterai quelques propositions
mais réflexions sont le fruit de
remarques remontées du terrain
elles sont inspirées par ma double
expérience à la fois de membres d'un
conseil de surveillance d'un petit
centre hospitalier rural sézanne dans la
marne cela était soulignée mais
également membre d'un conseil de
suveillance d'un centre hospitalier
universitaire régional ce celui de reims
ces réflexions en ce qui concerne les
permanences de soins
outre les frais 2
sur la permanence des soins coûtent an
en frais de personnel personnel qui
n'est pas soumis à une activité
constante et il faut prendre en compte
bien sur le tissu rural la faible
population mais également là la
spécificité les distances qu'il peut y
avoir par rapport aux grands centres
techniques mais également les
spécificités locales je vous dit ça
simplement je suis élu de sézanne situé
sur la triste nationale 4 août fréquenté
à deux voix et non pas deux fois deux
voies puisqu'elle devait être modernisé
en même temps concomitamment à la
création de l'autoroute a4 et sarr porte
avant les années 70 mais il ya toujours
pas eu de modernisation douze mille
véhicules jour 40 % le poids lourd
vous doutez que lorsqu'il ya des
accidents il s'agit d'avoir des antennes
de ce pur le long de la route qu'ils
soient particulièrement performance et a
contrario les urgences sont aussi
sollicités disons le régulièrement par
des gens plus pressé que nécessitant des
soins urgents
parallèlement il ya également les
l'égard de médecins libéraux qui sont
organisées partout mais quand elles sont
organisées ces gars ne sont pas
forcément sollicité je puis vous dire
que j'en sais personnellement quelque
chose dont il faudra bien je pense un
jour dans notre pays il ya une véritable
prise de conscience collective sur
l'utilisation à bon escient des services
publics et on voit bien les difficultés
que se pose lorsqu'on le veut améliorer
par exemple système de relais des d
urgence et de réponse aux urgences à
travers le rapprochement du 15 et du 18
lorsqu'il n'est pas fait de même on peut
souligner également dans notre système
l'impossibilité de payer des actes
médicaux ou des soins sur place dans les
centres hospitaliers
malgré la bonne volonté des gens ce
qu'ils ne responsabilise pas forcément
est ce qui montre bien la limite de la
gratuité par opposition aux dépassements
d'honoraires qui sont la partie extrême
de l'autre côté du balancier et il nous
faudra bien trouver un juste milieu si
nous voulons sauver notre système de
santé
une deuxième remarque en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement l'enseignement est source
de coût différent d'un établissement à
l'autre un les jeunes étudiantes une
tendance naturelle assure prescrire ce
qui n'est pas prise en compte dans la
t2a et la correction pourrait se faire
par le financement des missions qui
devrait peut-être prendre dans ce cas là
une part plus significative une
troisième remarque en ce qui concerne la
recharge des fameuses mairie les
missions d'enseignement de recherche de
référence et d'innovation car la
recherche est un élément essentiel pour
la renommée d'un centre hospitalier
notamment universitaires et au départ me
dit on l'igas avait estimé à quinze
mille euros le coût par an par étudiant
qui faisait de la recherche
il n'est plus actuellement que 10 de 10
à 11 milles euros ce qui pénalise les
laboratoires et qui coûte aux
établissements concernés
donc les chu cette mission de recherche
révèle terre relève t elle
entièrement du financement par la
sécurité sociale
la question est posée et cela mérite
qu'on s'y penche
je m'attarderai un peu plus sur la
quatrième remarque en ce qui concerne
les numerus clausus l'augmentation du
numerus clausus mme était véritablement
indispensable pour les universités sous
dotées mais cette augmentation a conduit
à baisser le niveau requis pour accéder
à la formation en médecine
automatiquement donc le tutorat on est
plus lourd
ce qu'elle est ce qu'il ya eu
différentes conséquences et notamment
pour les chu nouvellement surdotées qui
sont soumis à travers cette augmentation
à la triple peine dans les régions
difficiles avec une démographie
défavorable comme c'est le cas
spécifiquement champagne ardenne les
inter ne restent pas ils partent à
l'issue de leur formation première peine
les gardes interne nécessite un
accompagnement
elle ne ramène pas d'activité tarifées
dans le cadre de la t2a
mais créer une dépense supplémentaire
par exemple l'exemple type les
interventions chirurgicales
plus longue lorsqu'elles sont effectuées
par les jeunes internautes chirurgie
elle mobilise davantage d'heures de
personnel médical et paramédical
deuxième peine et puis le nombre de
professeurs n'a pas augmenté
il en résulte des heures supplémentaires
consacrées bien sûr à la formation ou
détriment des actes rémunérateur
troisième peine en ce qui concerne
madame le ministre maintenant les
contrats pluriannuels d'objectifs et de
moyens
ces contrats pluriannuels sont une
procédure intéressante mais parfois
hasardeuses les nouveaux ses poèmes
2012-2017 sont actuellement proposées
après concertation mais sans
connaissance des moyens réels qui ne
seront définies qu'en fin d'année en
fonction de la répartition définitive
des enveloppes par la rs et notamment
pour les missions d'intérêt général
si les objectifs sont fixés les moyens
ni sont pas une adaptation du dispositif
doit être envisagée car il est difficile
d'avoir une vision des objectifs sans
avoir une visibilité budgétaire
en ce qui concerne maintenant l'ondam
pour contrôler les dépenses de sécurité
sociale
l'idée de maîtriser l'augmentation
annuelle de l'ondam les déterminants de
l'eau dames sont d'une part l'influent